passion bien alors on va vous faire vous
allez voir les interviews
quand ces bases d'être là c'est bon je
veux dire valérie lemercier quand c'est
pour bouger comme ça vous pouvez bouger
parce que nous y voilà vous êtes la
personne qui bouge bien pendant l'été
une gueule mouche super dit voilà vous
savez bouger pendant une si c'est vrai
alors de bouger vêtus de rouge et par le
digg
si vous étiez président la république sa
semelle si j'étais donc si vous étiez
présent dans le public
ouais si j'étais président de la
république moi ouais c'est pas parce que
tu mettrais bécassine au ministère des
finances
non si j'étais président de florence
pavie remarqué quand je serai très fort
sur le dossier du vote des étrangers
ouais très attendu vous pouvez aussi
vous en faites pas ce qu'en français non
j'ai pas de passeport français je
travaille en france je paye des impôts
marocain passeport canadien canadien
voilà voilà
le passeport canada c'était pour voyager
circuler plus librement à travers l'eau
alors que voudriez un passeport
fonctionnement n'ont pas spécialement et
je deviens fou si vous avez trois
passeports non mais je vais devenir
schizo du parfait ah oui mais qu'à trois
passeports non mais voilà je travaille
en france j'ai le droit de travailler en
france une carte de ces voulaient voter
en france
oui oui je pense est important on
participe à la vie française payer vos
impôts en france
ben oui donc ça serait normal vous
retire enfin oui je pense si vous étiez
un sans-papier feriez quoi j'aurai le
portable d'emmanuelle b
si vous étiez dieu si j'étais dieu je
dirais in god we trust à une promo vous
étiez le diable c'est le diable
j'arrêterai mes conneries en algérie
sérieusement ouais ouais vraiment si
vous étiez mohamed6 qu'on appelle m6
entre nous si j'étais moi même si ce nom
mais au maroc
les gens l'appellent m6 c'est aussi ça
ne se faisait pas non pas du tout
sexistes et si j'étais moi même si je je
ferai construire un théâtre à casablanca
comme y en avait il ya très longtemps
qu'il a été détruit pour je ne sais
quelle raison je ferai construire un
très beau théâtre à casablanca
il faut lui dire mais je pressens ils
regardent l'émission oui je le sais quoi
elle regarde chirac aussi bernadette
aussi mal à l'aise tu nous regardes et
bien et dieu sait réduit je regarde
toujours dieu si vous étiez élu barak ne
feriez quoi
si barak le patron d'israël ehud barak
ehud barak pardon je serai la paix avec
moi-même d'abord je vous étiez à rabat
je suis changer la couleur du chef c'est
toujours la même depuis des années si
vous étiez bill clinton
je me remettrai au saxo si vous étiez un
fan de gad elmaleh j'arrêterai parce que
je me rendrai compte qu'il ya des choses
bien plus intéressantes
en tout cas c'est michèle bernier au
foyer quoi je dirais qu'ils passent à
vous étiez philippe bouvard ont été tout
mon argent